situation once again at a UFO has landed  in America the only country UFOs ever  seen to landed  humans of Earth my quest has led me to  your planet give it to me you should in  no way take any of this personally it's  just business Galax our mr. president we  need a Hail Mary patch we need raw power  wait a monsters say hello to  Insectosaurus don't scare Insectosaurus  it's okay buddy I'm not gonna let the  human hurt you here we have the missing  link a 20,000 year old fish man  Papa's a little out of shape dr.  cockroach PhD I'm not a quack and a mad  scientist  oh dear we call this an indestructible  gelatinous mass hi I'm Bob as you could  see he has no brain turns out you don't  need one and our latest addition she's  50 stories tall with enormous strength  and size what do people scream when they  see you coming you know i season susan  neck ooh I just scared myself experience  a monstrous event in IMAX 3d